em bolonha e hoje é ver o que falar
sobre uma doença é uma lavagem e sobre
os esforços que nós no instituto de
ensino é claro que não estou vindo para
cá para tentar encontrar uma vacina
contra essa doença
penso que a europa volte a ter a ouvir
falar da malária
talvez não saibam que é uma doença
causada por um parasita
o presidente chama pelas móveis podem
fingir em diversas formas ao longo do
seu ciclo de vida
é é uma doença transmitida
obrigatoriamente por um vetor que é um
mosquito é sendo que existem diferentes
espécies de parasitas móvel capazes de
causar alarde nos sensuais
o mais conhecido e mais motivo é o
plasmodium falciparum que entenda que o
que causa maior candidata a senhora da
glória
portanto há uma opção dada essa que
acontece sobretudo na áfrica subsaariana
e em crianças até aos cinco anos de
idade
a modalidade é extremamente elevada é a
propriedade também e portanto há um
conjunto de estratégias questão é que
são utilizadas para tentar reduzir o
impacto desta doença e com isso é já
conseguiram alguma chance contra alguma
diminuição da mortalidade associada à
malária através de um conjunto de
estratégias que visam ampa tendo o
parasita outro vetor
mas antes de falar nessa estratégia
vamos ver como é que o parasita e o seu
rosto dela uma interagem para decidir
esta doença é transmitida como eu fiz
por um mosquito que injeta o parasita no
seu quarto da romã quanto eu quando fica
para as alimentares à presidência na
corrente sanguínea e viaja até ao fígado
onde vai enfrentar o chelsea filha de
multiplicar se multiplica saem cerca de
20.000 parasitas cada um que entra dá
origem a nove mil
tudo isso sem quaisquer sintomas
enquanto por exemplo está no fígado não
né não há sintomas de malária e os
sintomas aparecem posteriormente
enquanto o presidente é o deputado pra
frente sabia e feto gov
assim aparecem os sintomas da malária
pois alguns destes parasitas podem ser
ingeridos por um mosquito e é vital
continuar 15 com uma nova indicação como
eu dizia há algumas estratégias que têm
sido implementados para tentar combater
a doença e já conseguiram algo voltado
em andamento a utilização dos fármacos
eficaz contra ela faz ambiente da
infecção portanto quando a pessoa está
doente existem drogas existem fórmulas
que permitam eliminar o parasita mas
também a estratégias que visam impedir a
transmissão da doença nomeadamente
através de redes mosquiteiras e de
inseticidas que é tá com o vetor o
mosquito o que não há e faria toda a
diferença numa numa estratégia de
erradicação da malária é uma vacina e se
separarem o bloco que assassina mas nada
faz dos cinco que acontece no fígado
por que que eu vou alcançasse nesta fase
porque todos os todos os esforços têm
sido feitos até agora mostram que as
vacinas que tomam nesta fase os cinco
são as mais promissoras são aquelas que
demonstram maior eficácia e dentro
destas aqui há uns que realmente têm
dado melhores resultados são as nossas
cidades de vacinas de organismo inteiro
da seleção organismo entende porque como
o próprio nome indica se baseia na
utilização do parasita no seu todo como
gento fascinação vocês vêem aqui é uma
glândula salivar um escrito cheia de
parasitas cheias foram somente como nós
chegamos nesta fase do circo e são estes
foram os vídeos que são administrados
como gente de vacinação
claro que não são administrados em
tratamento prévio estes parasitas são é
em 11 anos através do processo estão
bairros tenham sidos r tornam se
incapazes de causar a doença nas pessoas
e são os parasitas anuários que
constitui essa sina
isso tem dado excelentes resultados mas
há um problema é e o parasita entre nós
brasileiros e franceses é o próprio por
fácil
o parasita que causa a doença das
pessoas portanto se essa conclusão do
parasita não forçamos identificas corre
o risco de o parasita nós temos usar
como gênio vacinação
na realidade poderia ser um agente da
doença e até o nosso laboratório
tentamos pensar numa forma de
ultrapassar esta má alimentação de forma
que nós poderíamos deter toda a eficácia
reconhecida do de uma vacina que o
organismo entregue controlaria sem ter
associado qualquer risco de segurança
para explicar qual foi a nossa idéia eu
vou montar as origens da vacina são as
origens da seleção sinto mãos no século
18 quando este senhor é porque ela
desenvolveu a primeira vacina que o
mundo conheceu a primeira cena que o
mundo conheceu foi assassinada com
tráfego rua e foi foi descoberta das que
informa o guardian observou que não é a
época em que iria muito além da
pirataria era imensa
havia muitos hoje para se estar
protegido contra contraiu a essas
pessoas eram pessoas que estavam em
contato com as vacas fazem orgânica das
vagas
acontece que existe um vírus da varíola
humana mas também existe um vírus da
varíola bovina equipe médica já pensou
foi se criar o contato dessas pessoas
com o vírus da varíola bovina está
protegê los contra o vídeo sobre uma
peça foi potter um pouco e para
conquistar o que o fez foi inocular nas
pessoas
o vírus da varíola bovina e depois
esposas a romana efetivamente essas
pessoas estavam produtivas isso vou uma
grande campanha de vacinação contra a
varíola foi inclusive ambiental de
algumas críticas e conheça um cartão
neto quem mostra é algumas das críticas
que faziam na altura em que bateu na
saída das pessoas porque eu estava na
rua a inocular no vídeo ouve nas pessoas
mas o que é certo é que ele essa
estratégia de novo ano vírus que não é
patogênico para os seres humanos que é
parecido com isso confere proteção de
aumento contra
contratado em romana e com isto o vídeo
seria uma foi clarificado pela
organização mundial de saúde em 1989 mas
agora nos perguntamos o que isso tem a
ver com larga tem a ver com o marido o
cinto porque este conceito que esta
vacina da varíola trouxe é trouxe ao
nosso conhecimento e ao conceito de
esporte usar um organismo que não causa
doença das pessoas mas é conhecido é um
familiar no organismo que causa a doença
nas pessoas e usariam o primeiro é o
primeiro organismo como jeito de
vacinação contra que o cli causa da
doença nos seus mash e acontece na loja
também existem diferentes formas do
parasita diversas espécies do parasita
com diferentes hospitais
o palm falciparum é efetivamente o mais
emotivo dos parasitas da malária que
causa a doença nos rins mas há outras
espécies parasita plasmodium que causa
um mal área noutros animais nomeadamente
rui dores e em concreto o plasmodium
berghei é um parasita da malária do
windows não causa doença nas pessoas
precisava ser um parente próximo do
parasita humano e não é suficientemente
próximo para em muitos aspectos não
aplicar aquilo que o parasita humano
fácil mas é suficiente é diferente para
não causar a doença nos seus lugares e
até o cachorro ver qual foi a nossa
proposta nossa proposta é concretizar a
aliança documento ordena fez de fascinar
convite da língua vinha para proteger
com a província andre humana
nós propomos assinar com o parasita da
malária em roedores para proteger contra
la em humana nos com um estágio final do
projeto não é possível é nós hoje em dia
ter as formas de modificar geneticamente
as presilhas e portanto nós podemos
introduzir no parasita do windows
proteínas do paraíso em tomar
é como se nas graças do brasil
o windows parece tomar conta destes um
casaco para assim tomar no trânsito ruim
longe
isso para mim traz metricamente
modificado continua a ser um parasita
cuidadores continua a ser inócuo
continuam a causar alarme nas pessoas
mas vai embora no méxico gerardo
parasita humano e esta marca pode ser
apresentada aos elementar em uma manilha
desta forma o sistema imunitário humano
moto uma resposta dirigida ao parasita
que infecta regionais
portanto esta é a liga só resulta da
nossa ideia utilizado para visitas o
idoso não tá velho para seres humanos
mas geneticamente modificado forma
aquilo é 200 ao sistema evitará uma
componente do parasita humano para que o
nosso sistema imunitário e aprenda a
responder contra o brasil tomar esta
ideia foi apresentada a fundação gates
há cerca de 60 anos e desde então vamos
a cabo um grande conjunto de
experiências que o movimento eu não vou
estar aqui só para terem uma ideia do
tipo de abordagem que nós que nós
empreendemos eu estaria me explicar
algumas das experiências fundamentais
foram factos e nomeadamente a nossa
demonstração de que este parasita não
leitores geneticamente modificado
consegue enfrentar o fígado humano e
isso é fundamental que aconteça porque é
durante a infecção do filho que a
imunidade é gerada por que nós queremos
para que a vacina o possa ser porque a
torcida possa ser eficaz
o nosso trânsito melhor geneticamente
modificado
tem que ter a capacidade de infectar o
filho com uma e isso acontece nós
demonstraram através de diversos modelos
laboratoriais que efetivamente o nosso
brasil é que nós propomos os acordos
assim não consegue infectar as células
do fígado mama e portanto gerar
imunidade o que não queremos que
aconteça é que essa frase tem feto os
logos formais humanos porque iria causar
na área e nós mostramos que efetivamente
isso não acontece
utilizando trabalho em outro conjunto de
outubro tutoriais nós demonstramos que o
nosso transita geneticamente modificado
não consegue enfrentar os jogos do saco
mar
então nós temos um parasita que faz
parte do ciclo que nos interessa que
faça que enfrentar as chamas e práticas
onde a imunidade foi fácil disputada da
oferta os golpes mais humanas o que a
acontecer seria perigoso porque ele
poderia salvar a doença
essa foi uma das constatações iniciais
não fizemos e depois utilizados ao longo
de vários anos um conjunto de modelos
animais foram vacinados por nossa vacina
utilizada nos quadros utilizamos o igor
se utilizam de macacos vacinados com a
nossa assim na nossa nossa candidata a
vacina contra a malária e em todos eles
judeus animais o que observámos foi que
a vacinação com o nosso presidente é
geneticamente modificado o 'viva a
produção de anticorpos específicos
contra o parasita humano ou seja assim
estava a fazer aquilo que espera que uma
vacina faça o que é pode ser
administrada organismo responda criando
anticorpos contra o organismo para o
qual nós queremos proteger efetivamente
nesses três modelos animais foi
exatamente isso que aconteceu
a fascinação qualquer um deles com a
nossa vacina o voto em função da grande
quantidade de anticorpos especificamente
a conheciam o parasita humano por
falsidade
com base nestes resultados nós
avançarmos para ensaios clínicos em
seres humanos a em voluntários saudáveis
foram vacinados com nosso transita por
administração por picada de mosquito e
eu sei que isso parece um pouco estranho
mas é essa forma de é experimental de
administrar uma vacina deste tipo é por
picada de mosquito porque teórico para a
própria vacina que o parasita vontades
foram vacinados coordenação da china e
posteriormente resposta ao presidente
uma pra ver se não tinha como dar um vá
a alguma proteção contra
precisei tomar e os nossos resultados é
reutilizado recentemente mostram que nos
juntar os vacinados
a odebrecht de cerca de 90% na cara
depois informando que capaz de infectar
o filha dos voluntários quando estes
estão vacinados ou seja a situação o
nosso transita do idoso geneticamente
modificado leva é é um tiro no organismo
mas montou uma resposta imunitária e
consegue reduzir a carga da infecção
subseqüente compra assim tomando em mais
de 90% em off mesmo resultado é que
ainda não é feito porque nós não
queremos 93% queremos 100% tensão para
bloquear completamente infecção mas é
uma indicação do que a nossa ideia é
algo fora da caixa é efetivamente tem o
potencial de criar equidade contra o
parasita da malária tem potencial de vir
a constituir depois de mais trabalho uma
vacina eficaz contra lavagem e este
conceito de utilizar o parasita
corredores do top model berger como
plataforma fascinação por ser alargado e
podemos com os poderes perfeitamente
considera que tal como nós fizemos um
parasita de roedores mais esperado do
plasmodium falciparum que foi o que eu
fiz e vou falar até agora também podemos
conceber que se faça um parasita cuidou
esperado depois morre um viuvário que é
outro dos parasitas que causam a malária
em seres humanos e contra o qual também
não há uma vacina e em manaus podemos
comparar este conceito ainda mais nós e
obviamente é podemos especular que daí
da utilização do parasita que nos com
plataforma de apresentação de proteínas
ao sistema imunitário
pode ser que ele não só para a
presidenta da malária mas inclusivamente
a outros parasitas causadores de outro
doenças nomeadamente é uma isso daria
causa à leishmaniose o toxoplasma causa
toxoplasmose ou tripla na sopa que causa
a doença do sono
qualquer um destes organismos são também
parasitas também está em proteínas é que
são imunológica ou seja que são capazes
de provocar uma reação imunitária e isso
nós conseguimos mostrar nosso trânsito
ruim dos com essas proteínas
potencialmente poderemos ter uma vacina
contra essas infecções termina aqui
espero que tenham gostado e que a idéia
tenha ficado clara e até uma próxima
oportunidade